معنا الان من رام الله الكاتب والباحث
السياسي ساري عرابي اهلا بك سيد ساري
لنبدا بهذه الخلافات التي بدات تتصاعد
ليست جديده ولكنها كل يوم تاخذ منحى اكثر
علنيه واكثر حده هذا المستوى من توجيه
الاتهامات والقاء اللوم بين المؤسسه
السياسيه والمؤسسه العسكريه على ماذا
يؤشر يعني اولا يؤشر على ان بنيامين
نتنياهو وحلفاء بنيامين نتنياهو لا سما
حلفاء بنيامين نتنياهو في حزب الص يه
الدينيه والعظمه اليهوديه يريدون ان
يخرجوا كاسبين على المستوى السياسي يعني
بمعنى هي خلافات ذات طبيعه سياسيه ذات
مصالح ضيقه يخشى بنيامين نتنياهو ويخشى
حلفاؤه ان يدفعوا ثمن الفشل في هذه الحرب
سواء الفشل يوم 27 اكتوبر او الفشل في
مجريات هذه الحرب حتى هذه اللحظه ومن ثم
تسعى يسعى هذا الوسط السياسي بين يمين
نتنياهو وحلفائه من اجل تحميل المسؤوليه
للمؤسسه العسكريه والامنيه والحقيقه ان
هذا ليس شيئا جديدا يعني هذا الامر ظهر مع
بدايات الحرب وظلت هذه التسريبات وتبادل
الاتهامات حول من يتحمل المسؤوليه تحديدا
عن عمليه يوم 7 تشرين اكتوبر ظل مستمرا
منذ بدايه الحرب وان كان يعني ينطم احيانا
ثم يعود للظهور في احيان اخرى واضح ان
المؤسسه الاسرائيليه عموما بكل مستوياتها
سواء المستوى السياسي او المستوى العسكري
والامني او المستويات المركبه والتي دخلت
جديدا في سياق هذه الحرب مثل مجلس هذا
مجلس الحرب اركانه ولا سما نتحدث تحديدا
عن جانتس واضح تماما ان المؤسسه
الاسرائيليه لم تتمكن من طمس خلافاتها او
ارجاء خلافاتها في سياق معركه هي تقول
انها معركه وجوديه وانها معركه مصريه
وانها معركه تحتم وحده الاسرائيليين وحشد
كل الاسرائيليين خلف خيار الحرب وخلف
الجيش الاسرائيلي الذي هو الذي يقد هذه
الحرب يمارس هذه الحرب وجنوده يدفعون
اثمان هذه الحرب فهذا يدل من جهه على عجز
المؤسسه الاسرائيليه على تحقيق الوحده
اللازمه من اجل النجاح او الانتصار او
تحقيق انجازات واضحه في هذه الحرب وقد قد
يدل ايضا بالاضافه لهذه الاسباب الضيقه
على خلافات حقيقيه وجديه متعلقه بالاهداف
الكليه الكبرى لهذه الحرب متعلقه بمسارات
هذه الحرب وقد يكون ايضا الخلاف على هذه
الاهداف ايضا مرتبط باسباب سياسيه لان
بنيامين نتنياهو يخشى من ان يكون تحديد
الاهداف تحديد سياسات اليوم التالي قد
يؤثر على تحالفاته التاسيسيه مع احزاب
الصهيونيه الدينيه في هذا الاطار تحديدا
ما يجري الان ووفق ايضا التقييمات
الاسرائيليه في حد ذاتها هو اهداف لحظيه
فقط تنظر
اليوم التالي دون اهداف تخطط لمرحله مقبله
وهو ايضا نتاج هذا الخلاف وهنا تحديدا كيف
يمكن ان نضع ما قاله بيني جانس في اطار
هذه او هذا الواقع انه على نتنياهو ان
يختار اما الوحده والامن لاس الاسرائيليين
او السياسه وانقاذ
منصبه من جهه ما تصريح بيني جانتس هو
تصريح سياسي لان بيني جانتس يريد ان يظهر
بوصفه ايضا قبل ان يدخل الى مجلس الحرب
بطبيعه الحال وهو مجلس له يعني مهمه
اجرائيه مؤقته متعلقه بمجريات الحرب بن
جانتس وكان ايضا احد اقطاب السياسه في
اسرائيل واحد اهم الشخصيات التي يعول
عليها من اجل ازاحه بنيامين نتنياهو
ومنافسه بنيامين نتنياهو في قياده الكيان
الاسرائيلي بيني جانتس يريد ان يظهر
المسؤوليه يعني بمعنه يريد ان يظهر انه
يعطي الاولويه للوحده الاسرائيليه يعطي
الاولويه للمصلحه الوطنيه الاسرائيليه
العامه في انجاز اهداف هذه الحرب وانه
يقدم هذه اهداف الكليه العامه على اهدافه
الشخصيه او على اهدافه السياسيه ومن ثم
ينقل هذا الاتهام الى بنيامين نتنياهو انه
في حين ان اركان الحرب في اسرائيل بين
جانتس ايزنكوت وقياده الجيش وقياده الامن
في اسرائيل الجميع يتصرف بمسؤوليه عاليه
هذا الذي يريد ان يقوله جنتس فان بنيامين
نتنياهو وحلفاء بنيامين نتنياهو في
الصهيونيه الدينيه وحزب العظمه اليهوديه
وبعض اعضاء اللكود الذين يستخدمهم بنيامين
نتنياهو من اجل توجيه الاتهام لرئيس
الاركان وقياده الجيش هؤلاء هم وحدهم
الذين يتصرفون بانعدام مسؤوليه لا تنسجم
مع طبيعه هذه المعركه هذه نقطه ايضا مهمه
ضيفنا سيد ساري ما يحاول توظيفه سياسيا
بني جانس يلتقي ايضا مع انتقادات ياير
لابيد وهو ايضا من تيار يمين الوسط وكانا
في تحالف واحد ازرق ابيض في خوض انتخابات
سابقه هل نحن امام تشكل هذا المحور من
جديد اعتقد ان هذا حقيقي يعني في البدايه
سع كل اسرائيليين في الحقيقه الى حشد
المجتمع الاسرائيلي خلف خيارات هذه الحرب
طبعا ظهر في البدايه ان هذه فرصه ايضا
لتصفيه الحسابات السياسيه وان الانقسامات
السياسيه السابقه على الحرب ظلت موجوده في
مجريات الحرب ولكن كان هذا الصوت خافتا
الى حد ما واخذ ربما طابعا من النقد
المسؤول يعني بمعنى ان بنيامين نتنياهو
وحلفاء بنيامين نتنياهو هم الذين اوصلوا
كل الكيان الاسرائيلي وكل المؤسسه
الاسرائيليه لحاله من الترهل وحاله من
الفشل استغلتها حركه حماس من اجل تنفيذ
عمليه سبعه 20 اكتوبر ولكن مثل هذه
الاصوات الى حد ما تراجعت في مجريات الحرب
في سياق الحرب من اجل اعطاء دفعه لهذه
الحرب لكن ما لبثت هذه الانتقادات ان عادت
وما لبثت هذه الانقسامات ان ظهرت من جديد
من الممكن ان نتحدث ان جانب من هذه من هذا
النقد جانب من هذا السجال قد يكون جادا
يعني بمعنى ليس بالضروره ان يهدف دائما
الى تحقيق مكاسب سياسيه ولكنه يريد ان
يقول ان الذي قاد اسرائيل الى هذا الفشل
لا يمكنه ان يود اسرائيل في حرب وجوديه
مصيريه هذا الجانب من النقاش وهذه جانب من
الحجه التي تستخدم في السجال ضد بنيمين
نتنياهو وحلفاء بنيمين نتنياهو ولكنها
ايضا يعني تستخدم في سجال محاوله خلق
اصطفافات سياسيه جديده ودفع بنيامين
نتنياهو عن المشهد السياسي اعتقد ان كل
المشهد الاسرائيلي مدرك تماما ان بنيامين
نتنياهو عقده بالنسبه للكيان الاسرائيلي
وانه لا ينبغي لبنيامين نتنياهو ان يستغل
حربا مصيريه وقاسيه ومؤلمه على
الاسرائيليين بهذا الشكل كي يبقى هو فيما
بعد العقده المستعصيه الدائمه بالنسبه
لاسرائيل اسمح لي فقط ان انوه بهذا الخبر
العاجل واعود اليك بسؤال اخر اذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي تقول ان سلاح الجو بدا شن
سلسله هجمات في جنوب لبنان ردا على اطلاق
صواريخ باتجاه اسرائيل فيما يتعلق ب
واقعيه هذا الخلاف كونه ينطلق من واقع
الميدان وما يجري فيه نذهب الى ايضا ما
قاله وزير الدفاع من استغلال الجيش لت
تحقيق اغراض سياسيه ولكن ايضا من ناحيه اخ
اخرى الجيش في حد ذاته يبدو انه بات يظهر
انقسامات بين رئيس الاركان ووزير الدفاع
في قرارات داخليه الى اي مدى ايضا المؤسسه
العسكريه هي على المحك في هذه
المرحله اعتقد تماما ان المؤسسه
الاسرائيليه على المحد قد يكون جانب من
خلاف جالنت وحليف اجرائي كون هليفي يعني
شكل لجنه التحقيق هذه والتي يعود تشكيلها
الى صلاحياته واختصاصاته بطبيعه الحال
شكلها دون مشاوره مسبقه مع الكلين قد تكون
هذه الخلافات ذات طابع شخصي لكن ثمت
اشكاليه حقيقيه في الحقيقه تواجه الجيش
الاسرائيلي منذ فتره طويله حينما بدات
ملامح سياسه بنيامين نتنياهو وحلفاء
بنيامين نتنياهو لاعاده تشكيل المشهد
الاسرائيلي واعاده تغيير وجه الكيان
الاسرائيلي مره واحده والى الابد لا سما
من خلال ما يسمى بالاصلاحات القضائيه في
ذلك الوقت دخل الجيش الاسرائيلي على خط
التسييس وكلنا نعلم يعني عدد من جنود
الاحتياط عدد من ضباط طيران الاحتياط
الذين امتنعوا عن الخدمه في فتره من
الفترات او لوقت من الاوقات احتجاجا على
سياسات الحكومه الاسرائيليه ومن ثم كان
يبدو ان هناك خطر ما يهدد اهم عنصر يحفظ
الامن الاسرائيلي يحفظ ثقه اسرائيل
المجتمع الاسرائيلي بامكانيه الثبات
والبقاء والاستمرار في هذه الارض والذي
مثل تاريخيا الحاضنه لصهر المجتمع
الاسرائيلي حينما يعني دخل الجيش
الاسرائيلي على التسيس واضح تماما ان
المؤسسه قد تكون منقسمه حتى في اهداف هذه
الحرب وفي نقاشات اليوم التالي ومن قد
يدفع الثمن من جنرالات وقيادات المؤسسه
العسكريه تاليا طيب بعد اخر اريد ان
احاول ان افهم ان كنت تشاركني فيه التقييم
هنا ان كانت هذه الرؤيه والخلاف بين
المؤسسه العسكريه والسياسيه بهذا الشكل
وتاريخيا كان هناك لقاده عسكريين ايضا
مطامح سياسيه هل هناك بعد سياسي في
تصريحات القاده
العسكريين اعتقد ان هناك بعد سياسي في
تصريحات القاده العسكريين بالتاكيد لكن
بالدرجه الاولى هذا البعد السياسي ياخذ
مقدمه مهنيه يعني بمعنى ان عمليه سبعه 20
اكتوبر لم تهدد فقط المستقبل السياسي
لبنيامين نتنياهو ولكنها ايضا هددت
المستقبل المهني لقاده وجنرالات الجيش
والامن في اسرائيل وهؤلاء بالتاكيد
تاريخيا لهم طموح سياسي نحن نعرف ان
العديد من جنرالات الجيش الاسرائيلي وايضا
حتى من قيادات المؤسسه الامنيه
الاسرائيليه يعني كانت لهم طموحات سياسيه
سواء على مستوى محدود مثل الدخول في
الكنيست او يعني الحصول على بعض الوزارات
او اكثر من ذلك الوصول لقياده الكيان
الاسرائيلي وبالتالي ان يتحملوا وحدهم
المسؤوليه او ان يكونوا اكباش فداء للفشل
سواء 27 في مجريات هذه الحرب هو يمثل
هاجسا مهما جدا ولحوح على جنرالات الجيش
وايضا على قيادات المؤسسه الامنيه
الاسرائيليه شكرا جزيلا لك من رام الله
الكاتب والباحث السياسي ساري عرابي